[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui le
dessinateur françois boucq et le
scénariste nicholas junh coeur pour leur
bande dessinée un général des généraux
sur le 13 mai 58 et le retour au pouvoir
du général de gaulle alors que la france
est au bord du putsch militaire et de la
guerre civile ce qu'on a fait tout à
fait oublié aujourd'hui d'ailleurs tom
conan pour son nouveau roman pollution
qui se passe aujourd'hui pendant
l'épidémie de kovy des raconte un retour
à la nature de jeunes parisiens qui ne
sont pas au bout de leurs surprises et
l'historien bruno fuligni pour largo des
manchots petit lexique en usage dans les
taaf les terres australes et
antarctiques françaises et oui on fête
cette année le 250e anniversaire de la
découverte des îles kerguelen et qu'est
ce qu'on y parle aux îles kerguelen le
taf y en vous allez nous l'apprendre
bono fuligni mais commençons par notre
époque voici les images que vous avez
choisi pour la symboliser est bon on
commence par vous bruno alors voyez hein
on y est là on y est on y est on voit
des éléphants de mer mais derrière
deux bateaux dont le plus important est
le mar diouf c'est à dire le marion
dufresne
il porte le nom d'un navigateur du
xviiie siècle qui a découvert entre
autres les îles crozet mais c'est un
navire ravitailleur sans lequel il n'y
aurait pas de lien entre les îles
kerguelen et le reste du territoire
français cette photo nous montre dans un
paysage grandiose et bien à quel point
ces terres extrêmes que ce soit dans
l'arctique ou dans l'antarctique sont
devenus des enjeux de pouvoir et à quel
point les états investissent pour ses
terres et surtout les immenses zones
océaniques qui les entoure si on n'avait
pas les quarts gehlen on ne serait pas
le deuxième domaine maritime mondial la
venons en effet l'ensemble des taaf
représente un cinquième du domaine
maritime français le domaine maritime
français c'est plus de 11 millions de
kilomètres carrés soit 20 fois la
métropole
l'étape s'est donc 2 millions 300 mille
kilomètres carrés détendu océaniques
comme conan votre image à vous celle ci
s'est alors lui s'appelle spike en fait
c'est une peluche qui vient d'une spurs
d'un espace de jeu on l'avait gagné je
crois avec un ami et après il a des
écouteurs effectivement sur les oreilles
en fait c'est intéressant parce que les
peluches d'aujourd'hui sont beaucoup
utilisés par des adultes ce que ça vous
a pas échappé que je suis plus un enfant
mais malgré tout il ya je pense ça
symbolise des peuples ce qu'il ya comme
une improvisation à ses propres troupes
à l'époque dans laquelle on est le
divertissement permanent et de jeunisme
qui peut être quelque chose d'assez
grisant d'ailleurs et donc voilà donc on
donne des noms à des personnages ce type
un même spike a donc son propre compte
instagram par exemple mais ça oui les
quoi au départ on avait une mascotte des
jeux olympiques un départ non je crois
que c'est juste quelque chose qu'on
garde dans une fête foraine quand on a à
gagner vous voyez quelque chose et je
crois que c'était la fête foraine de
concorde dans la junte huileries
quelquefois rapport ni avec à dessin
animé il n'y avait qu'une barque de
spécialement mais par contre c'est aussi
en a je trouve ça avec ce qu'on appelle
le métavers aujourd'hui c'est à dire
cette vie additionnels dans laquelle on
aimerait nous emmener et où justement il
y aurait on serait tous un peu des
avatars donc des versions un peu
numérisés et cool is et cartes ou lisez
de nous mêmes donc je trouve ça
symbolise pas mal un peu de l'époque
dans laquelle on entre
effectivement votre image avoue françois
boucq oui c'est les pistes de ski à
difficile c'est à pékin ça oui ça et
donc ça ça me paraît tellement absurde
le monde dans lequel on est en train de
vivre le fabriquer des du de la neige
artificielle alors d'abord il faut pas
croire que c'est laid
les chinois qui l'ont inventée en
premier dans le nord de la france on a
des terrils sur lesquels on a fait du
ski et donc pourquoi
donc il ya déjà eu ça mais on n'avait
pas été aussi loin dans la facticité des
choses à dire que là on est en train de
faire de la fausse neige et on a j'ai
l'impression que en voyant tout ça on
est en train de nous prédire un monde
parce que ça c'est le début c'est le
démon du musée le début du monde futur
monde futur il est totalement
en fait lové à l'intérieur de ces
éléments là qui nous donnent des petits
aperçus à vendre des petits aperçus un
peu comme celui que tu viens raconter
avec les peluches c'est celle des petits
trucs comme ça depuis un moment donné on
va être dans un monde tellement
illusoire est alors bien sûr les anciens
les anciens ils disent que le monde est
illusion c'est une illusion mais on est
en train de fabriquer une illusion sur
notre monde d'illusions c'est vraiment
la spécialité circuits du monde attend
ça s'interpénètrent avant c'étaient deux
choses différentes il avait vous savez
lire rl et l'eurl irl pour innover life
et url qui était le numérique
aujourd'hui avec le projet de zuckerberg
et ça va vraiment se rencontrer on va
avec des casques de réalité virtuelle je
suis certain que ça va il est là on se
débarrasse dans le syndrome las vegas
c'est à dire on préfère la reproduction
le factice à quelque chose d'authentiqué
les américains préfèrent vraiment la
tour eiffel à las vegas que la l'autre
d'abord les plus petites voilà alors
permet d'être plus vite en hauteur et en
fait là on va faire du ski à pékin et on
arrive à convoquer le monde entier pour
venir faire du ski à pékin alors
personne ne l'a jamais fait
c'est ça le but mais ça n'empêche pas
d'y faire les jeux olympiques d'hiver
exact et donc je trouve ça tellement
symptomatique de ce qui est en train de
se préparer pour nous et qu'on va
dépasser par les choses qu'on va encore
nous fabriquer ça c'est le début nicolas
jeune choeur notre image avoué est en
noir et blanc
je veux un peu cassé l'ambiance
elle est pas franchement d'actualité
pourquoi j'ai choisi cette photo parce
que il ya gros à parier que les trois
quarts des personnes qui nous regarde ne
connaissent pas cette photo ne savent
pas qui sont ces hommes alors que ses
hommes
vont causer accomplir accompagner le
plus grand bouleversement historique
politique morale qui connut la france
après son mondial leur rôle est aussi
important que celui de de gaulle ou
mitterrand lire son jeu il y aurait
peut-être pas eu de goni de cinquième
république et pourtant ces hommes
personne ne les connaît en france donc
on l'a on peut les voir ces six hommes
c'est une petite photo qui pousse un
petit photographe à bab el-oued vers
octobre 54 je crois à alger
ce sont des fils de paysans des fils de
berger ils sont entre vu plusieurs fois
les semaines et mois auparavant là c'est
la dernière fois qu'ils se voient ils le
savent sans doute où les six vivent ils
vont lancer le pays dans une action dans
une série d'actions terrible ils ont ils
viennent de créer un mouvement qui ils
ont appelé le fln front de libération
nationale
et pourquoi je montre cette photo là
c'est parce que c'est pas pour faire un
hommage d'y accéder il faut faire des
sandero et il faut honorer krim belkacem
c'est pas ça mais il est inconcevable en
2022 alors qu'on va fêter le centenaire
de la guerre d'algérie le 19 mars arrive
je sais pas ce que macro on va faire
avec et 69 ans plus tôt
jusqu'au bout krim belkacem ainsi en bas
à gauche c'est le signataire d accords
d'evian
ellis en algérie la compagnie alors
trois vont mourir pendant la guerre
mohamed boudiaf et d'être assassinée en
92 et c'est prêt il s'accompagne sur
l'algérie mais ils ont un rôle en france
et aussi l'histoire de france à
l'algérie française jusqu'en septembre
c'est l'histoire de france et on ne sait
pas qui sait comment ça va il semble
impossible de faire un devoir de mémoire
- travail mémoriel où toi un conflit tel
que celui-là caravage est tellement d'un
mais d'hommes en s'acharnant à nier l'un
des acteurs principaux de ce
bouleversement cela dit on va parler de
votre livre on les voit très peu dans
votre livre oui c'est vrai ce que hydro
carole mais ça s'annonce à
58,58 ils n'ont aucun rôle mais sur le
reste du coup fumant certains alors
comment sont justement par ce livre
[Musique]
françois boucq grand prix du festival
d'angoulême en 1998 le prix le plus
prestigieux de la bande dessinée
francophone vous êtes donc le
dessinateur d'un général des généraux
qui vient de paraître aux lombards sur
un scénario délicieux il faut le dire de
nicolas jander sur le retour au pouvoir
du général de gaulle en 58 après 12 ans
et demi de traversée du désert on l'a
oublié mais il a fallu pour ça un putsch
à alger le 13 mai un comité de salut
public s'est mise en place dont le
général massu a été nommé président
c'est le début d'une aventure grand
guignolesque avec quantité de généraux
qui rêvaient d'une dictature militaire
on aurait vraiment pu sombrer dans la
guerre civile à ce moment là vous en
souvenez encore pour 58
ouais mais j'avais
avait trois ans
par contre après j'ai eu mes oncles et
tout ça qui ont fait la guerre d'algérie
et qui m'en parlait mais qui m'en
parlait d'une manière très très
sporadiques a réalisé un petit truc par
là il parlait de des tortures à la fois
qu'ils avaient subies et dédé c'était
abominable ce qui est raconté dans la
politique l'a dit voilà là on est au
moment où justement il ya des généraux
qui arrive est donc toute la farce comme
on décrit c'est la farce de ses généraux
qui est ce qu'ils essayent qui se disent
on va faire un putsch mais qui savent
pas vraiment comment le faire un peu
c'est les bricoleurs de putsch un
ccd mais qui vont à tâtons il faut un
coup par ci un autre par là et donc moi
j'ai reçu le scénario de nicolas et
quand j'ai lu ça je me suis dit ah ouais
c'est trop c'est trop rigolo à faire à
la fois je me suis instruit parce que
j'étais le premier à l'école du scénario
je connaissais à quelques éléments du
contexte mais pas la précision du
contexte et donc j'ai pu me plonger
dedans à la fois en le destinant et
parce que je suis obligé de le dessiner
je suis bien obligé d'aller voir les
photos des gars de quelle est la gueule
il avait sa nouvelle qu'elle aurait bien
fait segel la jso son magnifique en
morphopsychologie
c'est là on voit massue qui arrive mais
il ya aussi salon le général salan qu'il
chefs de toutes les armes et à ce moment
là et qui vient lui aussi sur cette
place du forum en algérie monte sur la
sur l'assuré tribune
presse alan bradeurs s'agit et qui
reçoit direct un camouflé et qu'il
renvoie la tayaba en fait que toute
cette aventure en fait et fait tout ce
théâtre c'est pour les gens qui sont en
bas c'est les algérois qui veulent
garder l'algérie française et
l'agitation à paris le bordel en algérie
fossé pour la conquête de ces gens là
c'est cela qui met qui menace c'est seul
qu'il faut calmer
oui c'est cela qu'il faut calmer mais oh
au départ ça semble faisable uzi bombe à
l'armée va suivre salants et là on va
lui donner un peu les pleins pouvoirs on
lui donne les pleins pouvoirs au départ
bon il ya plus de pouvoir civil à ce
moment-là alger le gouverneur général a
démissionné parce qu'il veut pas
supporter plus inquiets par des bonds
moins fine ce pays à paris c'est bon il
ya pierre philippe blain qui vient
d'être nommé m'enfin à paris on est dans
une valse de deux gouvernements la qui
s'enchaînent qui succès ya plus
récompensé les centristes et les
socialistes en général voient depuis le
début de la guerre d'algérie c'est les
socialistes en général qui sont là mieux
ou des siens tribulus andermatt be cool
voilà le penser mais tous sont
totalement des incapables bayal
reconnaître c'est à dire qu'ils ont ils
sont un peu bas comme l'a dit de gaulle
ils n'ont pas vraiment les outils ni les
moyens de toutes manières de mener une
politique à terme ce qu'ils sont ils
doivent rendre compte devant l'assemblée
de chaque décision que l'assemblée ben
il ya des pouvoirs comme idées et des
poujadistes et des communistes etc donc
c'est très très compliqué qu'il arrive
il arrive à rien même des plus grands
noms les noms les plus mythiques lépinay
les mendes on n'arrive pas à rester plus
de quelques mois la ville d'un
gouvernement donc tout va très vite et
la face à cette foule qui s'excitent à
une armée qui est complètement perdue
massue parce que massu aurait dû être le
premier barrage massue aurait dû dire tu
avais comme on arrive en bon on arrête
les bêtises il faut donner les parades
où on entre à la maison que c'est fini
la même semaine fut bon c'est même salon
il est entraîné mais c'est pas demain
parce qu ils sont aussi dépassés par
leur propre homme ça c'est quelque chose
qui sinon il se rendre compte très
rapidement ce qu'ils maîtrisent pas tant
que ça à leurs soldats et officiers
supérieurs puisque même le lendemain le
14 comptait 2 guen arrivent et même
chaussade 9 les quelques civils qui dit
de revenir et oui on va vous protéger
mais en fait ils seront tabassés par les
paradigmes plus tard ils sont obligés de
faire évacuer par un tunnel sous le
bâtiment il maîtrise pas trop trouve la
situation en fait il ya un moment qui
est dit sisyphe pour moi qui ai un peu
butin c'est quand salon va recevoir des
tomates et ça ça rappelle effectivement
les tomates qui avait reçu guy mollet
devenu président du conseil élu sur le
slogan paix en algérie il arrive à alger
il prend des tomates et là tout à coup
c'est plus la peur d'algérie c'est la
guerre d'algérie donne les pleins
pouvoirs à l'armée et salon c'est pareil
il prend des tomates et à partir de ce
moment là ou alors pour vous ces palmes
incident juste dans les tomates et a
priori historiquement il n'a pas pris de
thomas
je me suis dit qu'elle capture c'est le
symbole c'est le mot là le type qui a
effectivement pour être je suis désolé
france outre il faisait confiance
jusque-là le
mépris envers ces lits sorti une licence
en référence à molex effectivement sa
botte de la tomate qui évident et salon
qui est comme lourds pendant son
autorité n'a aucune autorité en plus il
est considéré comme le type qui a bradé
indochine on annule au napoli
complètement il est constellé de
décoration mais c'est à très bas il erra
nul c'est celle-là il est hautain
dédaigneux tout ça il ne faut pas
oublier que ce sont des militaires et
les minimes hier des bons parfois oui
mais ça reçoit des ordres et ça se donne
pas des ordres à soi même il faut que
les ordres arrive d'euros et là d'un
seul coup ses voeux qui se disent on va
se donner des sommes nous mêmes mais ils
veulent tous se donner des ordres
contradictoires on a la chance d'avoir
la chance vous allez me dire ça se
discute mais d'un bonaparte ou d'un
nouveau justement vous rendez chez nero
qui
parce que des hommes politiques a failli
ils sont quelque chose là dedans rien et
ça vous avez fait de vieilleries ils
sont pitoyables alors une fois on n'a
rien inventé il ya enfin si à part les
dialogues un peu de la mise en scène etc
mais la suite d'un enchaînement
invraisemblable événement bien ce
qu'elle fout c'est quand on est quand
même au bord de la guerre civile un
c'est du sérieux vous avez les pro
algérie française les antilles elle
gérait française vous avez et puis il ya
le
entre les militaires les politiques les
pros et les antis vous avez les
gaullistes qui sont là et qui essayent
de tirer le fil vous pour que park comme
par miracle leur homme providentiel
général de gaulle fait 12 ans et demi
qu'il est qu'il est plus nulle barre il
va peut-être profiter de la situation et
et on est le 15 mai et les salles en
criville de l'algérie française ou
balcon ce que veulent entendre les teams
qui sont en bas évidemment et on lui
souffle avant et un silence on lui
souffle à l'oreille et ça c'est vrai et
il crie vive de gaulle et à partir de
mort de ce moment là dans ce bordel le
nom du général de gaulle apparaît mais
les mecs ils ont travaillé en sous main
pour lui oui si l'on il ya ceux qui le
font volontairement et ce qu'ils font
involontairement je savais ni but les
hommes salon qui comprend pas fait et ça
c'est quand même assez extraordinaire
rien par tuer le moment le nom de de
gaulle est prononcé tout à coup ça va
cheminer plus ou moins rapidement dans
les têtes des plus ou moins doués et et
il va apparaître comme la solution et y
compris pour les partisans de l'algérie
française c'est à dire ceux qui sont en
bas sur la place du forum et les
militaires qui sont en haut il va
apparaître comme la solution pour que
l'algérie reste française ça leur paraît
la seule solution et on les laisse le
croire évidemment bien sûr y compris les
gaullistes qui ont prononcé son monde
qui eux aussi sont pour l'algérie
française et qui vont et qui vont se
faire avoir les debré les soustelle à la
seconde soit sous celle qui va être le
delbecque en question qui va très mal
finir aussi voilà telbec celui qui parle
à l'oreille des deux salons elle finit
soustelle pareille arrive va devenir le
chef de l' os le général salan qui est
la chef de l'oas le chef de la lfp avant
ça c'est le putsch des généraux qui
recommence en avril 61 c'est faux quand
gallas c'est une répétition en fait
comme ça n'a pas marché ils se sont fait
avoir ils essayent de recommencer et là
ils sont balayées mais par la part
intime qui qualifie elle c'est plus la
même chose à paris mais de gaulle il est
aussi finalement il devient aussi un
échappatoire pas que pour les projets
française pense notamment aux
socialistes qui ont vraiment peur d'une
guerre civile et d'un putsch et qui voit
en de gaulle le seul moyen d'éviter la
gare c'est parce que c'est bien joli de
dire non à de gaulle mais quoi la place
qui les socialistes et les radicaux
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord
personnes sont d'accord sur un nom c'est
plus possible ils ont tellement tourné
tellement fait gouvernement donc ils
sont paumés illicite de gaulle n'arrive
pas là le danger communiste bolchévique
tous à antibes bolchévique ou alors
c'est jerry française on les bouge à 10
hectares donc même les socialistes alors
les socialistes ça dépend lesquels parce
que vous avez effectivement des mollets
alors guignols on rigole auriol un
mollet lors yoyo ils sont baba ils sont
photographiés le voile sur les autres
vous avez aussi mitterrand vous avez
marre des gens n'est pas encore mis les
socialistes demandent esb plus de you're
le coup d'état pour eux c'est à coup
d'état web ils ont le coup d'état mais
aniston et oui en même temps on peut se
demander dans quelle mesure ils sont pas
mécontents de hurler au coup d'état en
sachant qu de gaulle va être élu ce qui
leur permettra aux yeux de l'histoire
d'être considérés comme comme des tic
vraiment propre cause que eux n'ont pas
voté au moins n'ont pas voté de gaulle -
qu'il n'y avait pas d'autre solution que
de voter de gaullier pas grand chose
d'autre à faire qui arrivera légalement
au pouvoir a même si l'armée en fait à
présent tarif qu'à ce moment là dacia
qu'il faut s'imaginer un type un général
un ancien général à la retraite qui
arrive devant l'assemblée qui ni bombes
écoutez vous me donner les pleins
pouvoirs jeudi sous assemblée pendant
six mois je vais créer une nouvelle
constitution
ben oui elle disputait la majorité c'est
magnifique on y va alors que ce lundi
comme il le dit dans cette célèbre
interview je vais pas commencer une
carrière de dictateur à 67 ans il dit
les pouvait les libertés publiques je
les ai rétabli je vais pas les enlever
et on peut lui faire confiance à de
gaulle miterrand effectivement et mendes
de lui feront jamais confiance
mendes est plus réservé les plumitifs il
a quand même des discours où il explique
que de gaulle c'est quand même l'homme
du 18 juin c'est l'homme qui tirait la
france brille il dit que d'après lui de
go ne verra jamais en dictateur à la
pinochet c'est plus un profil et la
salazar qui les inquiète c'est
oui nos féminines historiens donc je me
régale mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait des
des personnages intéressants dans la
quatrième république vous avez cité
mende spx derrière c'était des
personnages intéressants mais ils
n'avaient pas la stabilité et il ne
tenait pas l'armée surtout pas surtout
pas en algérie ce qui s'est passé sous
la quatrième république nous invite
aussi à réfléchir sur la proportionnelle
les députés était élue à la
proportionnelle ce qui fait qu'il y
avait jamais de majorité
et donc les gouvernements sautait à la
première contrariété
mais alors dans cette affaire ce qu'il
ya de formidable c'est de gaulle cette
histoire parce que de gaulle pente ou
votre livre ne dit rien ici il promène
son chien il journal il se fait faire un
costume ce qu'a été la vie de gaulle
pendant très très longtemps quelques
mois avant de redevenir de revenir au
pouvoir il se promenait en bretagne dans
le cotentin je crois en voiture avec sa
femme et son et son beau frère
il faisait des réussites joue avec ses
petits-enfants ils sont gardés à mort il
grèce l'année est d'ailleurs dans tous
les sondages on disait qu'il n'avait
aucune chance de revenir au pouvoir et
des persuadé que c'était foutu tout ça
est une aubaine néanmoins il ya un
certain nombre de gens comme delbecque
qui sont venus à québec
il leur a parlé on l'entend pas parce
qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'ils leur avis
mais mais est ce que véritablement il
est le témoin totalement passive qu'on
voit là et du conages dans le coeur oui
alors non il n'est pas cohérent passif
il a son bureau rue de solférino il va
toutes les semaines il reçoit des prix
de lier le musée intellectuelle ouais
bon ne criez pas complètement passifs en
revanche le fait qu'ils ne disent rien
oui ça c'est même s'il dit non le disent
les debré les faux car les guichard 10
mais il ne nous dit rien il fait des
borborygmes des fois il fait le bout du
nez quand même vous allez revenir au
pouvoir c'est du tout bon et puis non il
ne donne aucune consigne est la seule
chose il dit éventuellement où je veux
en venir appelé par la nation je refuse
de venir appelé par internationale parce
que je la reconnais pas je refuse d'être
appelés au pouvoir a mené par une un
soulèvement de pieds-noirs ce que les
normes des tests et moi aussi c'est très
bien comme ça et je veux pas être amené
au pouvoir après un coup d'état
militaire jouxtant la nation qui
m'appelle à la nation samedi mais a pas
de mode d'emploi pour ce à quoi ça tient
à un fil
ah bah oui c'était un film mais
delbecque des types comme delbecque joue
un rôle crucial absolument crucial on
voit très bien vous avez dû vous amuser
là aussi parce qu'on a l'impression que
c'est will que ce sont des delbecque des
gens qu'on a totalement oublié qui à un
moment arrive à relier les films et ça
tient à rien ça aurait pu basculer dans
une espèce de de simili le putsch
militaire comme on le verra en avril 61
avec un salon ou à massu ce qui aurait
sûrement pas durer longtemps parce qu'il
n'avait pas l'envergure mais en face qui
ont été quand même dommageable je suis à
peu près sûr que de gaulle était
totalement confiant lui à ce moment là
avoue qu'il savait des années comme ça
d'ailleurs ils savaient qu'ils allaient
revenir au pouvoir le tout était de
savoir qui manipule et et quels sont les
arguments les plus probants pour
l'amener à ce que disait nicolas
avoir les pleins pouvoirs mais par la
nation un come home providentiel
puisqu'il avait en tout cas c'est comme
ça qui se définissait au monde la
résistance comme étant celui qui avait
sauvé la france donc qui dans un climat
comme celui là qui on va chercher sinon
le même homme qui va sauver la france
mais qu'est-ce qu'on la corrida c'est
oublier un moment là des militaires le
10 mai de gaulle qui s'est enfin plus
personne ne sait qui c'est rigolo c'est
qu'il ya quelques jours on a visité la
maison de gaulle et on nous racontait
comment il était quand il était môme et
quand il était môme tout moment il était
comme ça il pensait vraiment son destin
écrit et look ce gars je suis sûr qu'il
avait une confiance inouïe en lui-même
d'abord il s'appelle de gaulle qui est
grand il peut manipuler les gens parce
qu'il plus intelligente les autres et
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui dit
pratiquement sans le dire en permanence
il y en permanence tout ça c'est les
glôglô c'est des gens ils vont aller 0-0
d'ailleurs il est des prises
et donc il pouvait que revenir c'est
évidemment ça se termine avec sa célèbre
déclaration je vous ai compris toujours
au balcon sur la place du forum à alger
il est venu tout début juin 58 il a le
pouvoir ça y est
il leur dit je vous ai compris et urbain
ils sont tous contents
moyens parce qu'il a plusieurs qui
relèvent qu'une telle série discours pas
une seule fois et se prononcer les mots
algérie française bien sûr pas mille
fois hélas déjà qu'il y ait un
gouvernement avec flimm l'un et mollets
sans soustelle oui parce qu'il a bien
fallu les acheter pour que pour que
l'assemblée lui vante les pleins
pouvoirs il a fallu nommer
mollet et puis un film un ministre sans
portefeuille c'est pour sa virée au bout
de six mois
c'est extraordinaire et vous avez raison
jamais le propose et c'est tout à son
honneur jamais prononcera le mot algérie
française puisque il est sans doute
persuadé que ça n'est pas possible et
que c'est absurde mais la phrase je vous
ai compris c'est quand même génial parce
que c'est un modèle pour moi c'est la
perfection absolue vous dis toujours je
nous ai compris et puis voilà et après
il leur restera les yeux pour pleurer
tout le monde se reconnaît un nom ne se
reconnaît que je suis et je suis compris
moi oui c'est génial et là vous faites
10 races allant vous savez monsieur je
me demande si on n'a pas fait une
connerie et je suis même pas sûr qu'il
soit capable de cette lucidité vous
l'avez trouvé où cette fois grâce à moi
qui nomme ruiz ces chiffres ainsi le bon
à rien ça c'est des mois ben non je
pense que salon il va être content du 8
et très fier d'ailleurs il a été le plus
froid que de gaulle tout après lui
refiler deux médailles de plus donc pour
agrandir la truck l'aspect de frigo sur
la poitrine qui était très heureux il
aurait peut pas voir de sixième médaille
mais sinon il aurait failli était
content mathieu été nommé général de
division troisième étoile c'est la fête
non effectivement la sauce moment à ce
moment les noms ils tous des visites et
de rien tout allait très bien il faut
voir aussi tous ces généraux quand même
sont constellés de médailles pour des
guerres qu'on a perdu oui mais ça c'est
une tradition française s'avère baisser
un peu de respect voilà quand même le
seul soldat le plus décoré de france
c'est juste un type qui a perdu plus de
guerre que les autres
on peut gagner quelques fois des
batailles en plein de lumière mais voilà
tom connor madame vous paraît très très
loin on m'a pas tant que ça j'ai quand
même étudié cette période là en cours
évidemment c'est une période assez
intéressante passionnante et pillant
sous cet angle là avec un aspect visuel
et humoristique un peu revisitée je
trouve que ça donne vraiment envie de me
plonger mais au delà de ça ce qui me
fera toujours c'est que j'ai
effectivement c'est ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure sur l'instabilité
gouvernementale ministérielle de la
troisième est donc là de la quatrième en
l'occurrence et donc moi ce qui
m'intéresse aux aveugles je suis
toujours un peu en désaccord c'est tous
ces candidats m'attend le savent et qui
va toujours faire la vème république en
oubliant un petit peu que cette période
là bon là c'était la crise algérienne
évidemment et spécifiques c'est un
contexte particulier mais c'était aussi
dû à la aux institutions qui étaient
extrêmement faibles avec huit mois des
gouvernements amené à démissionner très
souvent
donc en fait j'ai l'impression qu'on est
un peu en forme dans ce modèle gaullien
gaulliste de la vème république qui
avait déjà été affirmé je crois donc que
discours de bayeux en 46 donc
effectivement c'est assez anciens après
la traversée du désert laquelle vous
faisait référence donc voilà c'est une
période très fort d un temps j'ai
l'impression voilà la france se
constitue autour de ça pour le pire et
pour le meilleur et je sais pas vraiment
à quel moment est ce qu'on pourra
vraiment sortir quelque chose de nouveau
de ce modèle démocratique et républicain
là dans lequel il faut que la l'esprit
des institutions et même la constitution
l'a beaucoup changé depuis 1905 sur le
timbre donc le vendent à cinq ans le
fait qu' on pouvait être mis en minorité
en étant président de république donc la
cohabitation ski c'est la magie nabeul
pour le général de gaulle il l'avait
prévu mais c'était inimaginable mais en
fait tout ça a fait que ça des plus tout
à fait la même chose aujourd'hui que
c'est vrai mais j'ai l'impression qu'on
a presque renforcer ce mouvement la
future avec le quinquennat effectivement
que chirac que met en place en 2002 si
je me trompe pas parce qu'effectivement
comme maintenant il ya une concomitance
entre législatives et les
présidentielles ça donne un pouvoir
complètement exorbitant au président ou
à la présidente élue qui a donc
évidemment l'assemblée nationale
derrière qui a pas forcément à un
pouvoir de deux divisions très important
donc on a l'impression qu'on vit
vraiment dans ce régime très
présidentialiste beaucoup plus par
exemple que le modèle américain
contrairement à ce qu'on croit il est
bien s'intituler général des généraux et
ça vient de paraître aux lombards ont
fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
comme conan je vous avez reçus dans
interdit d'interdire pour votre premier
roman radical en 2020 et y est le
benjamin de la rentrée littéraire voici
le deuxième pollution toujours chez
albin michel au début de la pandémie de
co2 vie de votre jeune héros se
retrouvent au chômage partiel et part
dans une ferme du cotentin pour une
expérience de walking alors c'est quoi
le wild things are looking c'est ça fait
référence à une organisation en effet
qui met en place un site internet et
après concrètement des mises en relation
entre d'un côté des fermiers de l'autre
côté des gens qui veulent aller un petit
peu goûté aux plaisirs de la campagne
donc vous êtes vous est hébergée
gratuitement et puis en échange de
messages il devrait vraiment et une
lance c'est vraiment un concept c'est
vraiment une association qui existe
depuis peu près 50 ans et donc qui
permet cela l'international et puis
également en france et donc voilà en
échange du gîte et du couvert vous devez
un petit peu aidé au travail dans les
champs
je veux dire travailler le clapet les
vaches selon lui ce qu'il a à faire sur
la dent la firme en question en
l'occurrence la david le narrateur doit
s'occuper un petit peu effectivement de
quelques lapins et de quelques vaches
pas grand chose en fait il demande
d'ailleurs pourquoi ya pas plus de
boulot que ça pourquoi il a et on a fait
appel à lui à une autre nana qui
s'appelle iris qui vient aussi de paris
mais voilà en fait parce que c'est une
autre raison qui va en fait les amener à
leur tour des parisiens à la campagne
c'est de toute façon un sujet très
rigolo le cinéma
la littérature s'en sont souvent emparer
ouais on aime bien ça surtout enfin sa
date grosso modo de la vogue des babas
cool dans les 70 oui c'est le cas coup
on a prêté à la nature des qualités
régénérante c'est vrai mais moi il ya
même un film un jeu sera pu être de
l'autre mais le nom mais avec christian
clavier qu'effectivement ils datent de
cette époque là python il part dans une
sorte de ferme un petit peu docteur et
communautaire communautaire que la vôtre
tout à fait où effectivement c'était les
rapports sont très horizontaux il ya une
vision un peu anti capitaliste c'est
vrai ça m'a toujours assez séduit qui
même les films des années 70 parce que
on parle souvent de mai 68 mais en fait
l'esprit de sang suite à un peut
perdurer pendant soixante dix badiou il
explique ça très bien et donc on al
impression qu effectivement il ya un peu
un nouveau modèle de société qui doit
pas seulement à adopter des règles de
vie différente mais également un lieu
différent et donc effectivement quel
lieu plus différents que la vie kiva
région parisienne que le cotentin par
exemple tout cas qui m'a semblé être un
théâtre intéressé l'épidémie de covin a
été une bénédiction pour tous les
amoureux de la nature qui vous
l'humanité aux gémonies ouais plus on
est contre l'humanité contre les villes
contre tous comptes dont toutes les
abominations de nous avons été capables
plus on aime la nature oui on a envie de
retourner à la campagne il ya ce retour
effectivement immédiat cette espèce
d'intuition moi j'avais l'impression
effectivement pendant la période de la
pandémie puis encore maintenant parce
que ça continue quand même beaucoup à
germer dans les esprits il ya une
tentation de la fuite donc ce n'est pas
tant qu'on a vraiment envie d'aller dans
la boue de de prendre des grosses
chaussures et de planter des arbres ou
de s'occuper de lapins etc alors qu'on
l'a jamais fait de sa vie puisse occuper
de vache ça c'est quand même assez
compliqués et parfois assez répétitif et
assez ingrat comme travail même si c'est
évidemment très utile mais voilà c'est
d'abord une tentation de la fuite c'est
une une passion un peu négatif qui
effectivement qu'on ne supporte plus bon
la pollution éventuellement à proprement
parler au sens sonores visuelles
olfactives etc mais également après le
contexte je pense que ce qu'on fuit
aussi dans les grandes villes quand on
veut aller à la campagne jusqu'aux états
unis eut un peu le même mouvement sur la
côte est où les gens de la région de new
york qui se sont barrés en floride etc
dans une autre mesure aussi sur la côte
ouest en allant vers au texas c'est
parce qu'effectivement on fuit les
loyers hors de prix on fuit le travail
qui craignent de plus en plus précaire
des salaires qui sont pas du tout en
cours et les par rapport au coût de la
vie est effectivement une espèce
d'atmosphère un peu anxiogène du fait de
tout ça l'insécurité aussi les mentions
qui peut se greffer là-dessus et puis
voilà d un contexte de vie compliquée
qui fait qu'après les gens vivent
colloque jusqu'à des âges est
extrêmement avancé et c est donc voyons
ce contexte cela fait que ben voilà le
discours
consistant à dire pourquoi pas à tenter
l'expérience à la campagne à tendance un
petit peu à s'universaliser et touché
beaucoup plus de public dans votre roman
c'est aussi un face à face à ces drôles
entre le monde réel et le monde virtuel
c'est quoi pour vous d'ailleurs la
différence entre internet et la réalité
entre les écrans dans lesquelles tout le
monde passe sa vie aujourd'hui et la vie
c'est un peu difficile à dire vous savez
on parle de web 2 et de web 3 maintenant
le web2 c'est ce qu'on vit actuellement
donc les plateformes les réseaux sociaux
le web 3 c'est ce qui arrive avec donc
le métavers à laquelle je faisais
référence tout à l'heure je consacre
promet déjà depuis longtemps en mille
fois même en effet il merch immergé
réellement dans une galette et virtuels
en totalité et donc j'ai l'impression
que autant avant on pouvait un peu
séparer les choses là on voyait
quelqu'un on allait prendre un verre on
coucher avec quelqu'un dont vous êtes
faisait de manière réelle et puis après
éventuellement on pouvait continuer
l'expérience sur un sur une application
etc mais en fait maintenant les choses
sont vraiment interpénétrés parce que
finalement les mises en relation se fout
manière numérique ensuite les échanges
se font médias numériques il ya même des
relations purement numérique également
qui existent et qui sont absolument pas
marginal vraiment à ce qu'on croit donc
c'est vrai que c'est poussé par disons
les plus jeunes générations mais ça
commence aussi à la contaminer de plus
en plus de ce faire la société y compris
des gens voilà d'autres générations qui
avait forcément papa pas connu cela deux
au départ donc j'ai l'impression pour
rendre de plus en plus effectivement vu
que maintenant toutes les entreprises
par exemple se digitalise à outrance les
start up aujourd'hui en fait sont
devenus bah en fait les gars femmes donc
tout cet univers là en fait à tendance
vraiment à remplacer l'ancien monde de
manière quasi quasi complète avec des
enjeux derrière économiques et
stratégies qui sont tellement importants
et par exemple ce qu'on appelle un
concept qui est le concept de sky c'est
à dire le fait en fait d'avoir une
productivité toujours plus croissante et
ça s'est permis uniquement avec le
modèle numérique parce qu'évidemment si
vous fabriquez des chaussures bout d'un
moment donné vous aurez quand même
toujours besoin d'une certaine quantité
de cuir je sais pas de tissu pour
fabriquer vos chaussures si vous êtes
google si vous êtes facebook si vous
êtes airbnb comme c'est des plateformes
pouvait avoir un nombre illimité de
personnes demain invité des
extraterrestres a utilisé un bienne be
c'est possible puisqu'il ya un usage
illimité 1 ou illimité de personnes avec
une rentabilité qui est croissante et ça
c'est le modèle que recherchent toutes
les boîtes aujourd'hui donc c'est pour
ça que voilà ce numérique en fait va
pénétrer de plus en plus tout ça pendant
un mois ce qui m'a le plus frappé
pendant la pandémie c'est la livraison
de bouffe on a quand même un endroit où
en fait la livraison de bouffe se fait
essentiellement dans l'est il ya des
coins pour acheter à manger partout si
vous allez justement pleine cambrousse
il n'y a pas ce service de livraison
parce que c'est pas rentable via pas
cette personne donc en fait vous vous
empêchez juste là la personne de perdre
peut-être deux minutes en traversant la
route et en allant chez l'épicier du
coin dans un supermarché c'est quand
même invraisemblable on a créé des
besoins complètement superfétatoire de
mon point de vue mais pourtant ça a
fonctionné vous avez bien vu que ça
fonctionne aussi pour votre génération
avant avant la mienne bien sûr c est
donc c'est parce que c'est sous jacent
dans votre roman vous la voyez comment
exactement votre génération parce qu'en
fait c'est d'elle dont vous parlez oui
d'une certaine façon ben je la vois
comme une génération quand même qui est
comme dans une angoisse très très forte
encore une fois du fait de ses
insécurités très grande sur le travail
sur éventuellement la santé la mort la
guerre la pandémie a quand même vraiment
mis aussi le coeur de la brouille sauf
mans la polluer exactement je me suis
produit tout à fait et et moi pas rien
j'entends beaucoup de personnes qui me
disent oui mais tu sais moi qui ait des
gens qui sont par exemple en région
parisienne dans des grandes métropoles
françaises qui nice voilà moi je sais
que voilà je sens que je pourrai pas me
permettre le d'habiter dans des grandes
villes à lyon à paris à bordeaux ce sera
donc sans doute que j'irai à la campagne
justement revient à ça aussi parce qu'un
généralement on peut diviser par deux
c'est ce qu'on dit en tout cas après il
y avait que le coût de l'essence je sais
pas trop mais on peut potentiellement
diviser par deux le coût de la vie en
allant habiter à la campagne donc c'est
aussi ça en fait c'est des gens qui sont
perdus de mon point de vue qui sont
quand même dans une situation qui est
vraiment complexe avec de multiples
enjeux et a par exemple aussi la
question tout simplement sentimentale la
question amoureuse entre guillemets
puisque c'était quelque chose qui
pouvait rattacher les gens à un ancrage
stable à la famille pas forcément mais
même le couple tout simplement même sans
être mariés quoi que ce soit aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya quand même cette
précarisation est essentielle enfin moi
que je pratique et même que je célèbre
d'une certaine façon parce que c'est
vrai que l'algorithme à appliquer
relation amoureuse c'est à la fois
terrible et en même temps ça donne
beaucoup de possibilités vous pouvez
rencontrer des gens vous aurez jamais
rendu chez babolat dans votre milieu
parce que vous des calmes enfermés dans
des cantons a fait des choix des écoles
quand on vit dans une certaine ville
doit pas forcément vous allez dans un
microcosme il ya un an tu reçois qui ce
qui se fait donc c'est tellement tentant
aujourd'hui je pense que dire à
quelqu'un de ma génération entre
guillemets voilà
tu devras fréquenté cette même personne
pendant une éternité ou même pendant 15
ans c'est aussi débile que dire tu
garderas le même iphone pendant 15 ans
alors qu'il aura donc c'est très bien
d'autres modèles plus perfectionnés mais
vous les ramenez vous la voyez aussi
régressive et lucide votre génération
oui alors réglé si oui parce que en
effet à ça fait référence personnage de
spike dont je parlais tout à l'heure la
peluche dont il ya vraiment cette espèce
de jeunisme permanent dans lequel on est
on veut effectivement alors avec le
métavers c'est encore plus clair parce
qu'on sera un peu des espèces de perçage
encore une fois cartoonesque d avatar ça
ressemble vraiment en tout cas à ça sur
des applications comme snapshots et déjà
le cas vous pouvez pas avoir de photos
pas rien de sûr snapshot vous avez un
avatar de vous-même kirk est une sorte
de petit dessin animé très sympathique
d'ailleurs mais donc finalement on est
on est là dedans dans quelque chose qui
n'est pas exactement exactement nous
mêmes donc c'est un divertissement c'est
un jeu vidéo effectivement qui est assez
assez proche de notre propre vie devant
qu'on n'arrive pas à dissocier mais je
pense qu'il ya une profonde tristesse
parce que en fait on essaye de vivre de
mon point de vue des vies additionnel en
ajoutant en effet des comptes des
profils instagram ça même plusieurs
comptes possible je fais référence à un
conte qui n'existe pas il ya beaucoup de
compte aujourd'hui 2 sociaux comme on
dit qu'ils sont qui sont tenus par des
humains bien entendu mais qui font
référence des personnes qui n'existe pas
et par exemple comme ça un mannequin qui
s'appelle lille michela qui a des
millions d'abonnés sur instagram qui
vraiment facture à des grandes marques
du luxe des postes sur elle à sociaux
mais elle n'existe pas c'est un robot et
nous qu'elle s'appelle i'm rabat et elle
met ça sur instagram personne évidemment
ne tombent dans le panneau c'est pas le
problème mais donc on est vraiment là
dedans on est dans cette distorsion là
mais oui entre une face à nous rend
malheureux parce que je vois bien que
malgré tout dès qu'il ya un moment une
possible d'opportunités d'expérience
charnel on la saisit immédiatement mais
c'est vrai qu'on retourne très vite dans
ce dans ce métal birth entre guillemets
même par exemple au sein même des
conversations c'est très dur de ne pas
décrocher deux pas de décrocher le
téléphone pendant plus de dix minutes
dans votre roman ils vont découvrir un
scandale sanitaire qui n'a rien à voir
avec le fait que le crime le coc vide va
durer encore quelques années
et tout ça pourrait se terminer en
catastrophe mais ça c'est le roman il
s'intitule pollution il vient de
paraître chez albin michel
[Musique]
une fellini vous êtes historien vous
publié aux éditions hymne hémisphère
l'argot des manchots petit lexique en
usage dans les terres australes et
antarctiques françaises il faut
commencer par un peu d'histoire pour s'y
repérer les îles kerguelen
quand les armes ou découvertes sachant
qu'on va fêter cette année le 250e
anniversaire de leur découverte par le
le chevalier de kerguelen alors eh bien
oui c'était en février
1772 donc sous le règne de louis 15 mais
ce qui est surtout extraordinaire par
rapport à ce qu'on a dit précédemment
c'est qu'en fait c'est quelque chose de
totalement mythique inexistant qui va
amener deux vaisseaux de la marine
royale
dans ses parages c'est à dire que nous
sommes à l'extrême sud de l'océan indien
en s'approchant du pôle sud nous sommes
parlés
40e rugissants 50e hurlants des zones où
vraiment sur des bateaux en bois mue
sans moteur a uniquement par plaisir de
faire de la délégation là on est
vraiment dans les parages extrêmement
périlleux où on ne va pas on n'a pas de
raison d'aller ni pour combattre ni pour
commercer on ne sait pas ce qu'il y a
mais on croit savoir parce que depuis le
début du xvième siècle suite aux
histoires un peu merveilleuse racontée
par un normand qui s'appelait gonneville
et qui prétend avoir abordé dans un sur
un rivage extraordinaire avec un climat
délicieux des habitants charmant des
richesses infinies on cherche un
continent la terre de gonneville le
troisième monde va dire que à l'époque
on considère que bon la création et bien
fait on connaît la masse continentale
qu'il ya dans l'hémisphère nord on se
dit qu'en toute logique il doit y avoir
à peu près la même masse deux continents
dans l'hémisphère sud est ce qu'on
connaît évidemment à ce moment là c'est
l'amérique du sud c'est l'afrique le
compte n'y est pas ils ont procédé il ya
forcément un gros continent dans les
parties qu'on ne connaît pas et
ça sera vrai mais pas là où ils
cherchent et en l'occurrence les
français missionne kerguelen car jelen
c'est donc là marin
il a il commanda un vaisseau qui
s'appelle la fortune il ya un deuxième
vaisseau ce qu'on appelle une conserve
qui est dirigé par saintes alward voilà
kerguelen kerguelen va avoir 38 ans et à
la veille de son 38e anniversaire beau
cadeau belle surprise ils voient des
oiseaux de mer des oiseaux de mer alors
qu'on est à priori éloignés de toute
terre ça veut dire qu'il ya bien un
endroit où ces oiseaux se pose c'est
généralement 'l'indice d'une terre
voisine et donc il change un petit peu
de cap il essaye de comprendre d'où
viennent ces oiseaux le 12 avril 1772 y
voit une petite île qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui encore l'île de la fortune
donc là ça devient vraiment excitant et
puis bientôt le soir alors là ce sont
des falaises c'est une terre entièrement
nouvelle qui a l'air très imposante et
donc il qu il se dit ça y est j'ai
découvert la terre de gonneville j'ai
découvert le troisième monde et alors
qu'est ce qu'il fait beck repart tout de
suite en france avec leur propre session
comme ya quelqu'un qui dévalorise lui ne
descendra jamais nos yeux ses membres
alors il va laisser l'un de ses
officiers de bois guaino qui va prendre
possession il va perdre de vue le second
bateau ça conserve alors au bout d'un
moment bonbons considère que ce bateau a
dû couler puis leur part en france
l'ironie de l'histoire c'est que le gros
ventre donc ce second bateau va
continuer son voyage se rendant compte
que ces îles sont pas très intéressantes
va aller beaucoup plus loin il va
prendre possession de l'australie donc
lui découvre vraiment un nouveau
continent mais il meurt avant d'être
revenu en france et on ne saura que
beaucoup trop tard que l'australie
aurait pu être guerrier des nouvelles
maps et kpn lui est un politique donc un
officier politique lui ai donc qu'est ce
qui le fait il revient
en métropole il va devant le roi il va
devoir ministre de la marine et là c'est
le christophe colomb français il a
découvert enfin ce continent et ce à un
intérêt d'autant plus grand que la
france vient quelques années plus tôt de
perdre le canada donc il y avait une
nouvelle france qu'on a perdu là il ya
une nouvelle nouvelle france qu'on va
conquérir et pendant quelques mois alors
il passe devant tout le monde en termes
d'avancement il est vraiment un héros
mais il a décrit un endroit mais
difficile à décrire moi j'ai bien il a
décrit ce qu'il a vu c'est à dire une
cargaison d'aidé falaise savait pas un
îlot il a découvert quelque chose qui
semble massif le problème c'est qu'on
libère maintenant faut y retourner et
puis il faut débarquer et puis faut
colonisés alors bon il ya un second
voyage en 1774 est là il faut bien se
rendre à l'évidence c'est pas si petit
que ça des kerguelen c'est à peu près la
superficie de l'accord 7215 kilomètres
carrés mais c'est tout c'est pas un
continent c'est juste un gros archipel
c'est inhabitée c'est à peine habitable
on n'est pas encore au pôle sud mais
enfin c'est très frais sinon glacial
c'est extrêmement venteux il n'y a pas
d'arbres il ya tellement de vent que les
arbres n'arrive pas à pousser il ya
effectivement une flore et une faune
intéressante mais tout ça est
complètement rats et ne se prête
vraiment pas à un établissement humain
surtout avec les technologistes si j'ose
dire du xviiie siècle et quand il
revient alors là kerguelen le christophe
colomb français tombent en pleine
disgrâce en plus on se rend compte le
condamne à six reprises oui oui il est
dégradé il est radié de la marine il
faut dire que bon pour le second voyage
il avait déguisé en mousse une
jeune femme de 13 ans qu'il se réservait
pour son usage personnel il a été
évidemment dénoncée par les autres
officiers tout ça avait beaucoup frustré
et donc ça aggrave et un petit peu son
cas et donc il va se retrouver
effectivement en prison il aura quand
même sa revanche parce que tout en étant
à un noble de vieille souche est bien
lorsqu'arrive la révolution du coup il
va se retourner contre la monarchie et
il va mettre ses talents au service de
la république alors cesser cet archipel
qui ne sert à rien vous racontez
également que après la seconde guerre
mondiale on s'y attendait il faudrait
quand même qu'on en prenne vraiment
possession qu'on a quand la rendent
c'est à nous quand il faut il faut qu'on
y fasse quelque chose sinon elle va nous
passer sous le nez ça y est josy le
français entre temps que les gouvernants
terre adélie aussi en anglais arctic
donc c'est ça les taf et et apatrides 49
ans va y mettre une base on va voir les
photos il ya une piste d'atterrissage ya
des missions scientifiques qui viennent
là régulièrement et au fur et à mesure
là on voit la capitale port au prince ce
qu'on appelle paf en confiant et les
habitants sont les patients et les
rivières bien voilà c'est une anglaise
qui se mord glace alors on parle
français avec d'un graffeur française
mais enfin il ya des expressions qui
n'appartiennent qu'à cet endroit que
vous avez répertoriés dont vous nous
donner les explications
bon ce livre par exemple mais ni paix
qu'est ce que j'avais bien manip et ça
veut dire rien ça veut dire partir en
manif une manip alors au sens
scientifique c'est une manipulation mais
par extension c'est toute excursion
promenade balade manip et c'est sortir
de la base on vit à 81 cents personnes
enfermées dans la base mais dès que le
temps le permet on sort on va se
promener en respire des esgaulx donné
par lego dont ce sont des des cailloux
et en particulier des pierres précieuses
ou semi précieuses des chalcédoine dongo
donné ça veut dire aller les ramasser et
puis surtout les façonner pour en faire
de jolis souvenirs très pas des pierres
qui valent une fortune mais ceux qui ont
fait un hiver austral et bien sont
heureux de ramener ou d'offrir à leurs
proches ses précieux godon passé à lagos
d'alsace et quand on lit ce vocabulaire
quand on la prend soin on voit bien en
quoi ça consiste légale n 1 le peu
d'animation qui y régnait et qu'est ce
qui peut les est enchantée ceux qui ceux
qui séjournent de garrotter par exemple
parce garroté c'est pour éviter de
s'ennuyer voilà c'est à dire une souris
c'est un trouble dans le kent adore
semences et les effets des efforts et
des éléphants de mer dit les pachas et
donc vous risquez de si vous tombez dans
une solide être absorbé par ces sortes
de boules à et donc le le fait de ce
gars au tc de mettre une sorte de
lanières de chambre à air qui bloque le
haut de vos bottes pour éviter d'être
d'être aspiré en quelque sorte dans ces
troubles les ça veut dire aussi son
soulier ça veut dire aussi boire il ya
un langage figurer derrière ces
expressions qui ont trait à la vie
quotidienne là-bas quelqu'un qui sont
souvent c'est quelqu'un qui prend trop
de l'ouzoum le nous étant le vin rouge
d'accord et élingues est il inquiet
c'est passionnant parce que à la base
c'est un terme qui vient du vocabulaire
des anciens fauquier au 19e siècle une
élingue et c'était un d'une corde une
ficelle où on mettait des morceaux de
cétacés ou d'éléphants de mer évidemment
tout ce travail là disparu aujourd'hui
mais 500 fois toujours lorsque il ya
vous avez une cordée de gens qui
évidemment les uns derrière les autres
pour se protéger du froid pour éviter de
perdre quelqu'un en route progrès ce
soit aux kerguelen soit plus encore en
terre adélie où le climat est beaucoup
plus hostile et seringues et horst
linguet s'est transportée à l'aide d'une
seringue donc là il ya un anglicisme une
seringue c'est un câble vous permet de
relier une charge à un hélicoptère
d'accord rien à voir avec celle un gain
nom est loyal disquaires ou j'agis
prononce comme un disquaire et sa série
des y est ce ke r oui c'est à dire que
beaucoup de termes qui ont trait aux
kerguelen se termine par le xkey rq1r
donc pas poker c'est le pompiers samu
caire c'est l'hôpital etc le disquaire
c'est le chef de district des îles
kerguelen donc celui qui commande en
quelque sorte dans ce territoire là s'il
a une femme qui est avec lui c'est la
disquette des sa résidence et la
discothèque évidemment et les bib ou à
l'efb hibou sur les assistants du bib
qui évidemment est le toubib c'est à
dire le médecin celui qui règne sur
scène mulcair c'est cette photo est très
intéressant parce qu'on voit à quel
point les îles kerguelen c'est loin
puisqu'on s'est amusé à calculer c'est à
dix mille kilomètres de rio c'est à
12000 km de moscou paris sait combien un
bon point à quinze mille à peu près de
15000 4016 4500 kilomètres de capetown
donc la ville la plus au sud de
l'afrique 4500 kilomètres plus loin et
presque tous et honore évidemment et et
tout est pratiquement tous et et au nord
c'est assez fascinant le pop chat c'est
quoi alors le pop chasser le
scientifique qui est chargé d'étudier la
population des chats qui bien sûr ont
été introduits par mégarde par par
l'homme mais on l'appelle aussi le peep
show puisque son rôle consiste quand
même en partie à observer des
accouplements encore et alors le siloc
le synox selianov et un au départ bon
c'est une simple abréviation pour celui
le scientifique qui est chargée
d'observer le ciel nocturne mais
évidemment comme il est toujours un peu
dans les étoiles ça évoque aussi le mot
argotique cinoque il ya beaucoup de jeux
de mots en tafia oui oui le type qui
regarde les étoiles toute la journée
forcément il décide d'aller un peu
cynique et et le kopeck le kopecky a une
consonance rue ça mais en fait tu as
écris c'est au pe c'est c'est le
contrôleur des pêches mais c'est vrai
que pendant de longues années ce qui
pêchait dans les eaux des kerguelen avec
une licence accordée par la france
c'était des soviétiques et d'où ce jeu
de mots sur coop est contrôleur des
pêches celui qui qui contrôlait ce qui
motivait le paiement d'une redevance en
kopeck où j'espère on est ce que ça
n'était pas celui aussi qui surveillait
les russes qui éventuellement surveiller
les femmes à tout le monde surveille
tout le monde il ya eu aussi un
programme commun de lancement de fusées
atmosphérique en pleine guerre froide
c'était quand même curieux en entre 1967
et 1974 et donc le pas de tir à
l'abandon aujourd'hui un de ces fusées
s'appelle fusent offre donc là où c'est
une petite consonance russe françois
boucq
tag hélène ça vous inspire je me demande
c'est quoi la population de ces îles en
fait ils arrêtent ya pas de population
permanente l' avantage par rapport à
l'algérie 1 c'est une colonie sans
autochtones sans indigènes sens
et la population et et renouveler en
permanence à dire qu'il ya environ entre
80 et 100 personnes essentiellement des
scientifiques des techniciens quelques
militaires des femmes seulement puis 95
des femmes seulement depuis 95 qui veut
dire que quand ils arrivent ils sont
obligés d'apprendre le vocabulaire que
vous êtes en train de l'admirer d'où
l'intérêt d'un lexique enfin on peut
arriver aux kerguelen en connaissant
déjà le révélait alors qu'avant il
fallait
remarquer que la population des lecteurs
ch est entièrement renouvelée tous les
ans oui c'est effectivement
il ya une garnison militaire ce que
c'est pour être en bonne voie pour
imiter des généraux en plus indésirables
justement c'est pratique pour le montant
à payer envoyé massue ou le refuser des
gens qu'il ya quelques militaires ce
qu'on appelle les parts ex parti à
l'extérieur mais qui sont plus dans des
missions techniques
depuis le 19e siècle à plusieurs
reprises est revenue l'idée chez
certains d'en faire une colonie
pénitentiaire un bagne à guantanamo à la
française mais ça ça n'a jamais été fait
bien sûr c'est surtout une base
scientifique peur aux français elle a
été fondée par françois mitterrand qui
était ministre de la france d'outre-mer
en 1950 lorsque cette base a été créé ce
n'est pas une commune puisqu'il n'y a
pas de population permanente c'est
vraiment une base scientifique mais avec
une population permanente elle a été
créée à la fois pour des études
scientifiques mais aussi pour des enjeux
de souveraineté parce que la france cet
effet barboter plusieurs îles un peu
dans les parages lille beauvais
découverte au xviiie siècle et sur
laquelle s'étaient installés les
norvégiens 1927 et puis en 1948
l'afrique du sud s'était emparée des
îles marion marion découvert par marion
dufresne donc c'est pour ça que les
députés en 49 matchs à l'unanimité des
communistes aux gaullistes on dit dans
le ca va pas et ils ont voté une
résolution qui obligeait le gouvernement
à faire acte de souveraineté aux
kerguelen alors on a un député qui dit
oui oui vous savez il suffirait
d'envoyer deux trois gendarmes un
facteur et ça suffirait il ya un député
communiste on est au lendemain de
grandes grèves qui lance envoyé à
ceyreste on sourit on vote et à
l'unanimité et bien il est décidé de
créer une base ce sera le cas ce sera
fait en décembre 1950 avec port aux
français qui est toujours active
aujourd'hui et qui est une base vraiment
important pour voix derrière moi voilà
pour tous ceux qui étudient aussi bien
la faune la flore le sous sol le sol et
puis surtout l'immense en jeu
aujourd'hui des kerguelen et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut réhabiliter le chevalier
de kerguelen c'est pas le territoire il
n'a pas découvert un continent nouveau
mais il à doter la france d'un
gigantesque empire maritime ces deux
millions trois cent mille kilomètres
carrés que représentent les taf ce sont
des opportunités incroyables c'est un
champ d'expérimentation stations
d'observation pour les scientifiques qui
est colossal qui est encore loin d'être
véritablement connus donc c'est là que
il y à vraiment content pour elle d'être
les héros de tom conan le cotentin c'est
exotique imaginez s'il allait faire du
goût
car gehlen ya pas de fermiers la pause
débrouiller soi même il ya eu des
tentatives de colonisation
on a essayé d'y élever du mouflon corse
du saumon des reines mais à chaque fois
ça a tourné court les animaux s'y
plaisent mais les humains au bout d'un
moment décroche et puis il n'y a pas de
marché et donc il faudrait transporter
ensuite ce qu'on y cultive ou ce qu on y
élève si loin qu évidemment la
rentabilité nul
qui me frappe c'est que les jambes avec
largo dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
c'était hyper intéressant ça me fait
toujours penser à l'idée que finalement
la première forme d'art c'est le langage
après on peut toujours raffinés ont peu
de chauffage aux plus sophistiqués plus
industrielles plus compliqué mais voilà
le langage permet en fait un nombre
d'inventions absolument incroyable
c'était fascinant la discussion qui a eu
tout à l'heure j'ai écouté ça avec
délice et bien cet institut l'argot des
manchots les manchots c'est ce qu'ils
ont vécu ou séjourner plus exactement
aux kerguelen c'est eux qu'on appelle
les manchots ça vient de paraître aux
éditions commence à aimer se raidissent
faire voilà merci tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]